pigley to have a wild pitch watermelon
and out of here original oh it's like
shave jeez oh my god it's a string
string you know it's actually really
good it makes me feel like I'm having a
snack so like a marshmallow yeah your
first bite absolutely like a mush yeah
fun it tastes like we need Oh bazooka
I like the name I feel like they should
already be in my mouth this is the best
I bought me Sarducci one like a pebble
this is more like concrete than the
first one I chew on this when I'm
extremely engaged you know I know it
kind of reminds me a bit of a Beyonce
album whenever it comes out you have no
idea what's in it but you know it's
gonna be good double double bubble
that's my candy flavored dreams such
amazing talk oh so hard
there's no bubble no and it tastes like
bubble gum that's already been chewed
for about an hour like chewing on play
Leonardo DiCaprio cuz this gum is never
gonna win any awards but the difference
is that Leonardo DiCaprio deserves to
win an award fruit stripe I am getting
nothing on this you get taps low when
I'm sucking in my mouth I felt like I
got a paper cut
there's really sharp corners surprise me
you're a fan thank you so yeah like it
would remind you of a childhood because
it's the only time you'd ever eat it and
once you get to a certain age you
realize that it's awful and the novelty
of this had to be wears off so you move
on all the car went into the wrapping if
this was a celebrity it would probably
be shy of aloof why that's horrible
Oh Arbus the stylist in Australia I
really hope yeah but there's never been
a gun for me before
I'm excited to try this piggy smells
like I'm Kevin you know what I think I
have had one of these before in my
dreams
yeah this is no definitely something
these are all to Australia I want to
whole like box of these to take home
honestly like this is great show a day
probably reminiscent of Kanye can't
really like him even if you want to you
guys are a lot more experimental with
flavors very adventurous I feel like the
gum that America has to offer promises a
lot of things and then it just like
snatches them in the night it's like
haha you thought this is gonna be really
good but surprised you're chewing on a
rock and it tastes like hickeys alien my
Joseph it's alright now yeah is very
hard to kidding oh yeah Everly a thumbs
up songs are definitely they're very
colorful
the names of bit wacky yeah it's
definitely marketed very badly so how
Australian gummies yeah yeah it's really
comes a little bit more elegant in
comparison hmm the finest of films